se défouler pour mieux contrôler les
symptômes de psychose 60 des voix devant
nous sommes pas beaucoup
georges alexandre est schizophrène ses
hallucinations l'ont poussé à commettre
plusieurs vols qu'est ce qu'elles
disaient les voit pas quand mais il ya
un hic ce statut n'est pas le débat est
un personnage à l'écran
parce qu'il est malade il s'est retrouvé
dans cette nouvelle unité de psychiatrie
légale
j'utilise d'effecteur m&a dissipe un
milieu à mi chemin entre un hôpital et
une prison l'unité dernier cri inauguré
en mars reçoit 18 personnes des gens
comme didier jugé non criminellement
responsable de sont des vrais en fait on
indiqué dans un état qui leur permettait
pas de bien juger de leurs actes de
savoir les conséquences si c'était bien
ou mal l'unité offre d'abord suivi
psychiatrique serré comme sarah dernier
rendez vous de vos cinq ans
voir des ateliers de gestion du stress
et de la colère
[Musique]
avec en plus beaucoup de sport pour
faire baisser la pression
chaque patient vraiment son plein le
temps d'intervention plan de prévention
de la violence qui va avoir des sorties
en fonction de son plan puis des appels
de ses objectifs de tri l'objectif
leclerc mallohi la réinsertion chez nos
patients tout en assumant un risque
acceptable pour la société et pour y
arriver
l'unité de psychiatrie légale serait
plus efficace que la prison pour
réintégrer les gens atteints de maladie
mentale
on voit que les taux de récidive chez
nos patients ainsi qu'ils sont suivis
prise en charge est beaucoup plus faible
que chez les passants qui se retrouve en
prison des prisons qui peuvent
rapidement devenir un enfer
l'avantagé ici c'est d'arriver en bas ça
pour l'instant il existe quatre unités
de psychiatrie légale au québec un
modèle qu'on pourrait décider de
reproduire ailleurs
georges alexandre sera en novembre s'il
pourra réintégrer la société
ils pensent déménagé à joliette et
travaillé en restauration
pour réaliser son rêve ça va ça marche
très fort après se dévoiler